[Musica]
conoscete il termine safecast conoscete
il termine citizen science
non c'è problema li trovate su internet
in tre minuti è la terza parola che
vorrei usare la terza domanda se uso
l'espressione intelligenza plurale ecco
già questo su internet non si risolve in
30 secondi la quarta domanda è
conoscete la prova del telepass no
quella non c'è ancora su internet ma da
oggi pomeriggio da quando alla
registrazione in tra online sicuramente
ci sarà questa è la buccia quattro
domande
il nocciolo della questione che vorrei
trattare con voi oggi riguarda natura e
tecnologia però torno all'inizio vi ho
chiesto sapete cos'è safecast allora
torniamo a quando 2011 aprile il
terremoto in giappone nono grado della
scala distrugge il giappone e lo tsunami
crea un disastro e la centrale atomica
di fukushima è interessata dal disastro
le informazioni sulla centrale
all'inizio sono scarse
l'opinione pubblica è già tramortita
colpita dal dall'effetto anche
nell'immaginario potente della natura
che crea una cosa come lo tsunami
siamo abituati alle forze della natura
ma santiddio certe sono davvero
spettacolari grandiose minacciose gioito
è uno di quelle star dello scenario di
internet molto conosciuto da molte
persone ha fatto conosciuto da altre joi
ito non è laureato ma
in quei giorni lui giapponese quel
giorno si trova alle mighty a boston
stanno pensando di farlo diventare
direttore del media center del pd
proprio quella sera mentre si sta
discutendo se lui che non ha nemmeno una
laurea può diventare il direttore di
quella prestigiosa istituzione arriva la
notizia del terremoto lui alla famiglia
che sta a 200 km da fukushima come
immaginate è preoccupato
vuol sapere ma il governo giapponese è
reticente le informazioni
all'inizio ovviamente sono scarse ma
anche quando il quadro delle
informazioni si completa quelle sulla
centrale escono con il contagocce ci
sono state delle esplosioni c'è stata
una nube una nube tossica è come
chernobyl o no come fai a saperlo
il governo non dà molte informazioni che
fa gioito e uno dei maggiori esperti di
internet che esistano è un veramente una
persona
da questo punto di vista molto molto
addentro alle cose fa quello che fanno
tutti fa come facciamo noi
annaspa all'inizio finché si rende conto
di non essere il solo in mezzo a quelli
che stanno cercando notizie come lui via
via comincia a capire quello che serve
con un piccolo gruppo di persone unite
da una comune necessità avere
informazioni che il governo non dava
comincia a ragionare su quel che bisogna
fare crea safecast all'inizio un gruppo
di persone dentro e questa è la sua
abilità ci sono gli hacker ci sono gli
ingegneri ci sono quelli che sanno come
si fa se la rete di rilevamento della
radioattività è distrutta
bisogna creare una nuova rete con dei
contatori geiger
bisogna farseli santo dio è velleitario
dai tutto questo come fai
non sei nemmeno un tecnico eppure
insieme a te ci sono dei tecnici quando
uno comincia a dire serve un hardware
beh c'è e italiano si chiama arduino è
una piattaforma versatile semplice è
stata creata per soprattutto aiutare gli
artisti quelli che avevano bisogno di un
di un hardware economico per far
funzionare la ed luci robot mille
applicazioni possibili avversati in
arduino è un non è corretto dire open
source ma praticamente qualcosa del
genere è aperto e può benissimo far
funzionare un software che diventi un
contatore geiger con un'azione di
tutoraggio non diversa da quella che
ognuno di noi può trovare quando cerca
un informazione sulla rete come si fa a
fare la ceramica
ecco che si insegna la gente come
costruire uno strumento di rilevazione
geiger i soldi kurt starter o non so se
si dica esattamente così vuol dire
calcio d'inizio
un piccolo finanziamento che a volte
viene dato appunto da quella struttura
della rete che serve a sostenere i
progetti artistici ma anche progetti
come questo
in sette anni safecast è diventata una
struttura che raccoglie 16 milioni di
persone è la più grande rete mondiale i
citizen science per citizens ayane si
intendono reti di cittadini che
partecipano volontariamente a
esperimenti scientifici i più longevi in
questo campo sono gli astronomi
che da sempre si appoggiano ad astronomi
non professionisti per monitorare
porzioni dal cielo ma in vari campi ci
sono cittadini che volontariamente
decidono di aderire a progetti
scientifici rendendoli possibili se
volete se il cast è qualcosa del genere
ma è un il più grande progetto
scientifico del pianeta
nato dal basso da sotto come
disobbedienza civile a una evidente
mancanza delle istituzioni governative
giapponesi che non volevano dare quelle
informazioni
ora mi piace definire non safecast ma il
gruppo di persone che l'hanno generata
un intelligenza plurale la parola vorrei
chiarire in che senso uso questa
espressione
non sto dicendo intelligenza collettiva
l'intelligenza collettiva secondo me è
un mito nel novecento le chiamavano
masse in questo secolo almeno all'inizio
li chiamano social sono enormi serbatoi
di persone troppo grandi dal mio punto
di vista per riuscire a rompere la
solitudine degli individui che ne fanno
parte
per quanto riguarda le masse o
un'esperienza diretta avendone fatto
parte al treviso le masse erano
relativamente limitate anche nei momenti
migliori ma devo dire che comunque non
aggiungevano molta forza alle persone
per quanto riguarda i social non ho una
grandissima esperienza
però io vorrei ragionare da dilettante
come faccio questa sera vorrei ragionare
su un principio evolutivo noi siamo
animali sociali ed upi cacciano in
branco la nostra specie si è evoluta per
strutture piccole familiari three bari
di clan davanti alle difficoltà
quasi automaticamente ci mettiamo
insieme a qualcuno
i terremoti scatenano in noi sentimenti
che in altri momenti non si vedono e non
è un caso che le strutture che abbiamo
creato per affrontare i terremoti parlo
della protezione civile siano
organizzate con una catena di comando
corta e unita molto compatte e
autosufficienti di persone che possono
contare su di loro quasi sempre in
qualche modo questo tipo di strutture
che sono quasi fisiologiche si rivelano
molto funzionali molto utili nelle
startup negli incubatori di idee si
promuove questo genere di forme di
aggregazione sono è un modello che viene
riproposto più volte io preferisco
chiamarlo intelligenza plurale
circoscritta non di grandi dimensioni e
all'inizio safecast e questo poi diventa
una cosa di milioni di persone ma parte
da una cosa più piccola gioito lo
sottolinea il fatto che senza internet
non sarebbe stata possibile se il cast è
figlia sua e della tecnologia già a
questo punto
a questo punto dovrei chiedere a voi
quanto tecnologici siete da 1 a 10
zero ok no dai
padova e tecnologica più o meno di
venezia più o meno di milano ma di cosa
stiamo parlando
vi sentite più o meno tecnologici dei
vostri figli a difficile risposta anche
questa allora bisognerebbe chiarire che
cos'è la tecnologia risposta
assolutamente soggettiva dilettantesca
per me tecnologia e tutto ciò che è nato
dopo di me fine altri tutto ciò che è
nato dopo di me e che sono costretto a
imparare perdendo un sacco di tempo
perché mi hanno detto che così dopo farò
prima
se così fosse questa cosa la dico teatro
tutte le sei ore la gente ride più o
meno come voi non voglio fare repertorio
ma mi serviva questo passaggio
se siete d'accordo su questa definizione
soggettiva è evidente che tutto ciò che
ho trovato è perfettamente naturale
mentre tutto ciò che è tecnologico e
tutto ciò che viene dopo
quindi ovviamente la soglia si sposta
generazione dopo generazione
esiste un prima e un dopo per me
internet è chiaramente un dopo allora
c'è un rapporto che ognuno di noi ha con
la tecnologia che può essere
sintetizzato da quella famosa prova del
telepass ridammi la luce in platea poi
anche tenerlo un po acceso se vuoi così
vi vedo quella famosa prova del telepass
di cui vi ho accennato all'inizio che
era la mia quarta domanda è molto
semplice voi con la vostra auto
avvicinandovi alla sbarra del telepass
provate
fiducia o speranza wake già stamina il
piede st prudentemente vicino al freno
il nostro corpo nella parte superiore
esprime tutta la nostra moderna
accettazione della diavoleria
tecnologica ma la parte inferiore del
corpo e lì perché perché il telepass
ispira più speranza che fiducia e
irrazionale tutto ciò ma una spiegazione
antica la fiducia noi tendiamo a darla
alla natura la natura è quella brutta
bestia che provoca lo tsunami
il terremoto e e che ogni tanto ci fa
dei brutti scherzi ma abbiamo una
convivenza con la natura di migliaia di
anni
qualche decina di migliaia di anni forse
centinaia di migliaia di anni come
specie e dunque la chiamiamo madre
nessuno di noi chiama madre la
tecnologia la tecnologia offre a noi
speranze speranza che si alzi la sbarra
del telepass speranza che la scienza
trovi le cure per le malattie che ancora
non ce l'hanno quella cura speranza che
le cose diventano più facili che la
connessione con il mondo mi offre
opportunità che prima non avevo
sono evidenti i vantaggi che ho avuto
adottando la tecnologia digitale il mio
cervello analogico in qualche maniera si
interfaccia con una certa facilità
con questo linguaggio ma dentro di me
continua a non fidarmi fino in fondo
forse perché sono consapevole che della
tecnologia io in fondo sono sempre il
pilota collaudatore mentre con la natura
viaggia sul sicuro
dunque tornando
a safecast se joi ito può essere
considerato il padre di sel cast che è
la madre di sel cast
lo ha detto lui la madre di sel cast è
internet e chi è la madre di internet ma
noi sappiamo che internet ad un padre
tim berners lee nel 1990 91 battezzando
il web il linguaggio con cui in internet
le nostre i nostri dispositivi dialogano
trasformando ognuno di noi in editore
dialogano con linguaggi standardizzati
quello standard di dominio pubblico il
web ha un padre tim berners lee ma chi è
la madre del web a bisogna andare
indietro
prima il web viene dopo internet
internet
sicuramente come madre bisogna cercare
arpanet
certo la rete dei militari ma prima è
primo dopo cercando la madre arriveremo
a un transistor
ma la madre incerta noi battezziamo
della tecnologia inventori e li
chiamiamo padri ma esiste una linea
evolutiva della tecnologia essa nasce da
tecnologie precedenti ricombinate in
modo diverso come in natura esiste una
linea evolutiva una linea evolutiva
esiste in tecnologia associare le due è
una stupidaggine
l'evoluzione in natura a tempi e
modalità assolutamente diverse da quelle
della tecnologia e per di più non esiste
niente di così rapido e veloce come
l'evoluzione tecnologica ma la madre
resta incerta persa nel bosco misto
della tecnologia e questo non sapere che
è la madre o ignorarlo o dimenticarlo
perché semplicemente non ci ragioniamo
mai sopra secondo me fa parte dello
spaesamento che deriva quando
l'accelerazione aumenta i cambi come
quelli che abbiamo davanti due cambi
possibili di velocità
certo
oggi chiunque di noi è sincronizzato con
il suo smartphone il suo telefono
sapiens il cavallo di [ __ ] della
rivoluzione digitale
ma oggi siamo davanti a due salti
possibili di cui si parla si parla si
parla di internet of things e la
bioingegneria l'internet of things
l'internet delle cose per dio che ci
vuole immaginare di poter mettere un po
di intelligenza siamo talmente sapiens
che possiamo mettere intelligenza nelle
cose che ci vuole ammettere un chip
basti re la funzione trova la mia
ciabatta la ciabatta risponderà son qui
nella cuccia del cane e ti chiederai
dove l'altra sono l'ecocentro perché
perché tua moglie non trovava più la
prima ha buttato la seconda sono
l'internet of things
al momento sono qualcosa come 40
miliardi di sensori sparsi nelle merci
oppure sparsi nell'ambiente 40 miliardi
di cose che danno informazioni che
dialogano con gli dispositivi che invece
noi usiamo coscientemente tutto questo
ci mette davanti a una considerazione è
possibile
siamo diventati talmente bravi che
possiamo buttare via un po di
intelligenza metterla in prodotti che
non serviranno più non recupereremo mai
quel cibo costa talmente poco che può
stare in un palloncino in un micro
giocattolo per bambino a perdere a
perdere a perdere a perdere lo stesso
progresso parallelo che ci ha reso
capaci di lavorare su cose molto piccoli
e quello della bioingegneria il progetto
sul genoma umano è nato esattamente lo
stesso anno in cui tim berners lee ha
battezzato il web sono 27 anni fa
dovremmo esserci abituati invece no il
ritmo che ha cominciato a correre ha
prodotto la mappatura del genoma umano e
da quel momento in poi la nostra
capacità di lavorare sui geni e di
lavorare non più soltanto
sui singoli geni ma santiddio su interi
corredi genomici sui corretti sui geni
di sintesi quelli di craig venter sui
geni artificiali oggi siamo in grado di
mettere dei geni dentro dei
sequenziatori programmatori che hanno
dimensioni di circa piccoli siamo
diventati siamo diventando bravi non
come il dna che fa pochissimi errori ma
anche noi stiamo imparando a ridurre gli
errori con questo tipo di giochi tutto
ciò prospetta a qualcuno di noi un
brividino sottopelle la possibilità di
avere umani aumentati o non uso le
parole che vengono usate dai giornali
per generare in noi meraviglia la
sensazione che ho è che il gioco sia
quello di stupirci e piacevolmente farci
continuamente stupire dall ultima
rivelazione sulle scoperte tecnologiche
quasi sempre dimenticando che tra
l'annuncio e l'attuazione della stessa
ci sono di mezzo tante di quelle
verifiche per cui la maggior parte di
esse si perderanno sostituita da
qualcosa che nel frattempo è nato questo
è un gioco allo stupore che ci coinvolge
tutti siamo disponibilissimi ad adottare
le nuove tecnologie ma piuttosto
difficile per noi capire come noi ci
stiamo adattando alle cose che abbiamo
adottato dove abbiamo imparato a usare
le tecnologie
quindi viene un paragone vi ricordate
quando si parlava di mettere
l'educazione sessuale nelle scuole santi
dio ci hanno provato generazioni di
ministri e di cose e alla fine hanno
deciso che era meglio lasciar fare alla
natura
tranne la svezia la danimarca sono pochi
che hanno fatto davvero l'educazione
sessuale nelle scuole e l'educazione
tecnologica e non è molto chiaro ma io
dove ho imparato queste cose dal
dilettante che non ho imparato a scuola
su internet
quindi per imparare la tecnologia meglio
lasciar fare la tecnologia
d'altra parte anche per imparare la
sessualità oggi conviene lasciar fare a
internet può essere traumatico
l'approccio ma sicuramente ci si trova
tutto oggi il vuoto delle istituzioni
non riguarda solo le informazioni che il
governo giapponese non ha dato riguardo
alla centrale di fukushima
ciclicamente ciascuno di noi misura il
fallimento delle istituzioni nel fornire
quelle risposte educazionali legislative
il progresso tecnologico apre
costantemente il problema di un gap
lasciato indietro
questo edificio in qualche maniera un
emblema di quello che vorrei dire prima
vi dicevo ho definito l'azione di sé il
cast come un'azione di intelligenza
plurale e ho definito tecnologia tutto
ciò che è venuto dopo di me è in qualche
modo natura tutto ciò che ho trovato
quando quando sono venuto al mondo il
sistema teatrale appartiene alla natura
da questo punto di vista un po
riduzionista se volete però è
perfettamente normale per me
considerando come dato come naturale
il problema è che non c'è molto di
naturale qui casomai c'è qualcosa di
fossile qualcosa di storico
ma quel che voglio dirvi io riguarda le
persone facendo il mio lavoro io mi
accorgo di come questo sta cambiando
perché tutte le sere vedo gli avatar
a teatro non suonano più i telefoni
ormai non si fa beccare più nessuno no
si accendono diventano blu
perché si connettono convinti che
nessuno rivede non saranno tutti i
medici in servizio pensano cosa stanno
dicendo sono qua a vedere lo spettacolo
di paolini poi in inglese da to my a
l'essenza è devo restare connesso non
posso più farne a meno
il dispositivo ha cambiato la mia
fruizione del mondo
ora qual è l'unica risposta possibile a
questa moltitudine di avatar
a teatro diventare un hacker io
condivido il decalogo degli hacker che
tra l'altro il fatto di 11 articoli
sulla tavola della legge che sta sulla
facciata del building 32 delle mighty a
boston
lì c'è scritto cosa deve fare un hacker
trovatela non è difficile in internet in
qualche maniera penso che quello non
riguardi solo gli ingegneri che si
occupano della rete ma di chiunque
lavori in reti grandi e piccole come
teatri rispetto a quello che ho messo
nel mio titolo stasera il ritardo della
cultura sulla tecnologia william osborne
era estremamente preoccupato della
accelerazione mostruosa che stava
vivendo e formulò la legge del ritardo
della diciamo cultura immateriale sulla
tecnologia era il 1922 osborne era
terrorizzato dall accelerazione che
avevano le cose tecnologiche la
motorizzazione di massa e tutto intorno
a lui si rese conto che avevano una
velocità assolutamente diversa da altri
pensieri
insomma previde che adottare un
telefonino non significava
automaticamente adattarsi a lui
del telefonino cento anni dopo le cose
non sono migliorate quello che era un
ritardo fisiologico rischio di diventare
cronico oggi non si tratta di risolvere
credo il problema usando degli arduino
per far muovere le scenografie rendendo
lo spettacolo più tecnologico per stare
al passo questo può essere una risposta
ma secondo me non è così interessante
io credo che in qualche maniera
bisogna cercare di fare in modo che a
teatro si formino delle comunità di
intelligenza plurale che il rito del
teatro non veda nell'attore un
officiante più o meno stanco ma che in
qualche maniera provi a esercitare
voglio dire ci sarà pure qualche hacker
tra il pubblico in mezzo agli avatar
qualcuno in grado di raccogliere la
stilo spunto e ci sarà pure qualcuno con
cui condividere qualcosa di eccitante
qualcosa di divertente anche difficile
per farlo bisogna negare l'amicizia agli
spettatori non diventare complici dello
stile di vita piuttosto dirgli guarda te
stasera
questo è un esperimento il teatro
laboratorio e voi siete le cavie
voi siete citizen science vi avviso
prima fatelo consapevolmente lo so non è
facile se esagero se ne vanno e che
hanno un lavoro più ma in qualche
maniera la molla per mettersi insieme
imposti come questo bisogna provare ad
accenderla perché vedete se arriva un
terremoto la molla scatta da sola ma se
apparentemente non succede niente
è difficile far scattare l'intelligenza
collettiva e intelligenza plurale ma io
credo che stia succedendo qualcosa molto
in fretta
credo che dentro di me natura e
tecnologia siano come due zolle
tettoniche che ogni tanto
si muovono scatenando umanissimi
terremoti
mi è già successo e non ho nessuna
intenzione di restare da solo ad
aspettare che arrivi la prossima scossa
[Applauso]